[Applause]
1 one
one
we're going to open up as soon as
possible some questions from the
audience we've got our roing minds here
so do I question raise your hand I've
got an answer
already a genie once offered Robbie H
the choice of a a really long memory or
a really long Willie he forgets what he
said I'm going to write that down so get
it we'll be here all
we any this is for Danny and have you
ever kept of any cat have you ever kept
any of cat's clothes what the [__]
I have to repeat it for
Norman Norman
66 what was that have you ever kept any
of the cat clothes any of them all of
them
actually no I haven't you know believe
it or not I I kept the original suit
that I wore to the audition because it
was mine
anyway and that's it really I've got the
most original catsuit so all the rest
are just you know mer impersonation I do
want to point out though that Danny does
drive around on a pink motorcycle
wearing pink
Leathers I just like to say that me and
Bobby have been carrying this guy around
for the last two
years
on our shoulders I thought I'd get
before he lied to
you yeah I F it was in Australia it was
like this all day and
time Chris have an operation can't
talk when I
first when I first met Dy had this
Jeep and the registration number was
DJJ
A1 that says a lot about
is true I'm
scary when I met Norman he had
nothing we gave him a
[Applause]
career away from him and
hect with friends now we've got time you
can ask
question
good one of Chris's fans by the
way I wonder who she'll be asking the
question no don't try play down
now um there have be many snags doing
the F which we all love but is there is
there one that sticks in
[Applause]
your
mind any stick in your mind guys not in
my mind CU there's just so many every
day of me that I can't me me and Robert
specialize in SM yeah you do realize
that I've spent the last 25 years robt
Robert the weather's liines Ted to my
forehead yeah I could have just written
them on his
Package ohly C ladies and gentlemen it's
aous rumor ladies and
gentlemen your hands in questions so
they'll just go
hi now I want to know for everybody have
you ever been to redf
Bay Red Bay Ang where is it Ang Angley
no can you say it in well do I look
[Music]
well listen have you seen what you
[Applause]
[Music]
got he s to SAI Davis
Jr
they love you all singing Tong side
don't
[Applause]
encage now listen if you all sing it
will you come and do the
dance that be the
finale like stand that
song you don't like toaster blood awful
I didn't like the toaster at all I like
John manahan who did the voice he's a
lovely guy but the toaster I wanted that
character
out that toaster was having marital
problems tell you what he weren't the
only
[Applause]
one
years
back together all doing the same old
stick that we used to do when we first
start we've had running gags going
amazing I think we just always bantered
and took the mick out of each other and
that's how it's always been how you get
long it's like teams uh football teams
is it bantering in the dressing room and
stuff we don't share a
f
we only spoke to you CU we felt sorry
for
you you know listen without me the thing
would never got
[Applause]
started I'm the of the fact that Norman
can remember that far
back listen to show you how bad it was
when we met normany had
ha and all he kept talking about was his
football career that never happened
right and his heart attack and
his him had a heart attack I could have
been playing for England I could have
been a
fellow now me and Dav we both
66 he's got one stent in his arteries
I've got three
so who's who's the
[Applause]
man we should try and do another
do you think the red movie be made what
do you think the red door film be
made do you think the red fil not
Normy I've got the script for the
original one it's very very funny anyone
want to
BU I get so of why that couldn't get off
the grand really don't know that's to do
the people that control to answer that
question though we are just quite happy
to be making a sitc come again is
actually a sitcom back to didn't really
quite work that well because it was from
sort of quite filmally and it was only
when we got back to doing Red Dwarf 10
live studio audience and close sets
character based comedy and the fact that
Norman wasn't in it that made it
work and the thing is Steve C's doing
Alan cartridg as a film and it never
really really take Works does it we take
a a TV program to film it rarely Works
does it really so in a way it could be a
good thing that there wasn't a film
mate in a way though Adam and things
like that and the readers um oh that
they've got an
[Music]
advantage they've got an advantage in
the way though because they were sitcoms
that never were never played the live
studio orience you know so they were so
they sort of more drama basic anyway we
in front of an audience audience we're
we're show offs we and we rise I don't
know if you
noticed and we rise when we're in front
of an
[Applause]
audience you do miss the last track when
you watch B you miss the last
track yeah coration Street was a good
[Applause]
idea you wouldn't get that either
what was that green car
about what was that car was it a it was
a
car
smart and you put Wings on it or
something they put
Wings hi um have any of you kept any of
the props from the show of momentos only
[Applause]
nor uh we were given things I had I had
a model um Scutter which I gave to a fan
a neighbor of mine in edra when I lived
in Ed and I I wish I hadn't
now very fond of the scuts I like the SC
I I've got Dwayne diy's um
identification
tag I've got all list his jackets and
his boots and his TR and stuff like that
most of the props I broke
anyway definition of a working prop and
red La is something like such ja
it is also true that a long time ago
what happened will date it um Craig and
I were flying to America and the captain
was a fan of red wolf and he invited us
up to the cockpit and Craig sat in the
captain SE doing steering that they had
an
autopilot and and and I said to the
captain I I just want to explain to you
that the definition of a prop that works
on Red Door for something Craig hasn't
touched he went and then Craig looked
above him and there was a big switch
under c what does that one that was the
autopilot don't touch that one
cre tell you what if you got into a CO
of an airplane I'd just I'd be putting
it because yeah we had a new set brand
new wasn't it the blue [__] first day
we haven't even shot a ceiling yet so he
comes in sits here it's good this in
it you can
imagine now there's a guy called Peter
rag Hees us to make on this really
complicated weapons at bits of airs and
things like
that he was he was a nice
man from the from the school of
Thunderbirds oh P right Thunderbirds and
Daddy's from the acting school of
Thunderbirds all strings
in
very I I'll tell you what his anyone
seen that
Santander with um Rory DOL and all of
that that
[Applause]
is what's her
name you
know I don't know it J is that wooden or
is it
Me's in the show going if you want to
get
to no wonder Le hamton left
McLaren um we have do another sorry
we're talking about
red after all the Sur done which one did
you enjoy doing the most important the
most that is a Chris Barry question yeah
Chris come on I've been trying to get
through a whole Q&A without
[Applause]
speaking no
such I have gold
yeah don't talk like
that he put it on
now what
question which Ser could you enjoy in
the most I 10 series which series series
did you enjoy performing in the most um
up to and
including I thought uh back to Earth was
my
[Music]
favorite
funest I it's hor I don't I very hard to
pick I always picking episodes um out of
each series and and uh maroon was was
one of my favorites that's cuz me and
Robert were it
yeah um Dimension jump when you had Ace
R and smed R together and the wi good
and we wonder why you like that
one world world me
[Music]
squirt is covering you in oil oil yeah
they enjoys that
yeah nice nice Chris they still even
touch touch being
the he's never lost it
question sorry a question for all of you
what's your favorite quote from each of
you my favorite quote was a review that
we had one time in paper that tan said H
Craig Charles's performance reminded me
of a cheese and ham sandwich without the
cheese and
bread
[Applause]
[Music]
i' just like to apologize for swearing
that little boy there I'm so
sorry get the Grandad complex are you
get the name so when you say favorite
quote you mean from the show yeah from
each I'm fine take you
Susan
I got not start because mine just got
B everybody's
dead May June July and
August I always on the dog I love that
dog I always like she'll never leave
Fred and we know it
yeah
yeah I mean I I got the easiest one
aboard
[__] my favorite C is don't
ask what is
it series 10 my favorites um no we just
hosed him down and gave him
a bo
bo let me think Bazinga open
I I review that said um Polly's hair is
too long for a
computer well I tell you what I agree
[Applause]
that blood hair you see someone's you
know you've left the show and someone
takes your place and you see the hair I
thought Fu me that's any is going to go
right off the
screen I never complained just to
myself it was long wasn't it one stage
yeah what was that we were talking about
last night no bu
drinking I did that they asked me to do
that on a radio station recently will
you we'll do the other parts will you do
the lights and then they said we can't
do that one now because it's got bugger
in it and it's at
5:00 what on the radio honestly I said
was surely in Coronation Street they
must say bu silly it must say
that no you know what it is is that it's
like they always say
off my favorite is let's get out there
and SWAT
[Music]
it apparently you can't say that 5:00 in
the
afternoon well
mad
got this is for all of you I was
wondering if you could choose one what
would be the funniest episode that
you've
done you could choose an episode our
favorite favorite episode po oh I just
have one all the time mine's easy as
Queen that's my it is a H episode but I
thought it was great well written it was
beautifully written and qu the guy who
played que was great Charles all so
fantastic Danny Danny actually
suggested I didn't like that one I hated
being Supporting
Cast you got although we did we did act
actively campaign after the episode they
were so jealous they were so
jealous we wanted que to be the new
computer to
be favorite episod favorite episode's
really hard lemons is up there I like
lemons lemons
is
reality I like um
Maron I like what was that one where we
went into the
f I like that gunman of the Apocalypse
yeah quite difficult to choose one I've
got like favorite scenes more than
anything really I mean it's really hard
to seene with me and Robin doing the
polymorph with the shrinking sh
in your career mostly you're trying to
think of a scene that's any
good controversially quite quite like
meltdown I thought meltdown
wasd don't eyeball
me get down give me 100 give me 50 I'm
not sure I'll be allowed to do that no
my favor there's another Gandy who was
even older than that Gandy yeah he yeah
he was a standing Gandy he was a
standing
[Applause]
the car cuz he couldn't actually could
stand up I think Einstein went to
hospital Elvis was
phenomenal for the sky let me see them
on I haven't seen TR cars for about 5
years is that right or more true long
time and I'd like to yeah yeah we
haven't seen each other for now I never
saw him well I went to
bed done my comedy bit and what went to
bed and he did his I was DJ L DJing late
late at night but I'd like to thank him
for doing all the straight lines setting
up all my jokes for the first and second
series did a really great I was your St
you did a good job done your
St some have to make it look funny you
know what I
mean all project in between red like I
know robot wars and mass speed Captain
Butler who gets the most because of
little side
[Music]
things I who gets the P tap out the
most side project
side chall no well d the story
makers Captain Butler I captain Butler
Chris that when we play Lial football
agent yeah we we all admit we've done
some pony
rubbish I had a good series of my own
called I love it I love
it no one else did though
2 million
we how
[Music]
nor I love Rob Wars and I love it no I
love could have combined
side it's quite weird that me and Robie
both look messing around with loads of
[Music]
big
massive engines yeah ends up
a very strange crowd and now Daddy's
causing Death in Paradise he has to
spend five months of the year on a
Caribbean
Island I mean it's a good show because
basically people go on holiday and one
of them kills another one and at the end
you find out who did it and like benador
really and I think Miller is leaving the
show and Chris who's taking over D
um Chris Marshall Chris
Marshall he's going to be in it now so
that'll be
interesting yeah where are we all
right it's it's depicted in the show you
pretty crap at
Guitar can you really play guitar um you
want me to
lie like I am the living Incarnation and
Hendrix well I'm
not I can Chuck out a few power cords
play a bit of Rhythm I'm certainly
better in list but you know I'm not that
great not great sh to be honest although
I do think Lista should release an album
you know get back together with naate
arm death and just put on
now yeah baby you want do the
song sound like
Chucky where is he don't you move
boy hey Mr fli over there
yeah I love you all so
[Applause]
much she getting
prompted um if you children any got you
know what listen just take the microw
off pH away and Shout can't hear
you if you
any any PL line in Red Door Norman's
exit he did um what there was one time
when we were rehearsing when we didn't
we played our characters jealous when we
played our characters in a rather Camp
way which would be homophobic offensive
but it was quite funny and we wanted to
get we wanted to be hit by the gay we
went past the
planet we wanted to do it I still want
to do it the trou was it affected Kon
the least you really couldn't tell
you st the
same said Chris already did his gay Ray
and demons and angels yeah when he got
to we the spot and suspenders and the
stood through the nose and
he wouldn't take it off when he went
home you imagine so what is
it Julian Clary nearly sued
him I wanted Kon to have a baby that's
one thing I remember a little Bub and
kryon like that there was also another
idea about we went do thing called kon's
dream where kon's the only human and me
and and me and C and R are all robots
and I thought that would be quite a good
one cuz we tried kon's we song and it's
weird to make you look you don't look
like kryon you look you look different
he look different he paint his
black I've got it I've got the
bir and that' be a good episode an
interesting episode
anyway what with Elvis on the moon as
well Elvis on the
moon you're right keeping
[Music]
going right any new series
don't use the
mate in the series there no misquotes at
space col directives you going to bring
that back in the next
[Music]
one one un happppy
customer was all right but we with the
space c
director CHR Chris had in his contract
that there weren't to be no space for
dire I think a future series some of the
old ideas might be you know the ideas
from previous series might be Revisited
revisit sorry you got
right we not bringing the look virus
back
again that would be horrific go
that okay we go for another question
from the just shout do you have fre
found fiction about yourself and if you
do what's your favorite pairing
[Applause]
ever I try not read stories written by
dog bloody
nayor I once received a a a uh a scan of
a picture a very well- drawn picture
through via email pre- Twitter a few
years ago of a rather explicit drawing
of kryon and
kachy a little bit
disturbing I remember a rather
interesting letter that Bobby got once
about underpant and
Hangers the only way to to give it it
was written but to do it justice I have
to get near with the microphone you need
to be able to hear what you wear I'm a
costume
wet and like do you put your under pants
on
hles that's
REM Chris actually got asked a very good
question in the in the last Comic C
which I think it's one of the which is
from that you lady day now going to try
and hide yeah there she goes it was from
here and and she asked him had he ever
been asked by sexual partner to leave
theh on
well
open
[Applause]
up he just say you never going to see it
from where you're putting
[Applause]
your you know the H is for
head I was wearing it when we kissed
true it's true well that was one of the
best screen kisses of ever ever had and
they cut that really short cuz we had
[Applause]
it they didn't cut it
short and um and just out of pure
Badness my I smoked about he doesn't
smoke I smoked about 17 cigarettes
before the
scene and I 17
Polo okay we are running out of time to
R up
so
don't have a rubbish like what happens
to the fish they dropped on
you we had them I would home
[Music]
stinking there's like actually stuff in
in the archive somewhere where you're
playing in English AC English and
slightly Swedish so he he might have
been Swedish at one time we tried stuff
yeah like SM like SM so if he was
Swedish he would be speaking like
this I will just hang up your underp Mr
L the idea was
robot that's a Swedish should turn out
were jokes about he was very safety
oriented had side impact vs and airbags
and all that
stuff and there was loads of bits left
over that we can never wake up
with there's nothing down there except
plastic Onin and the
trademark but I think it was it was
meant to be Canadian which it so isn't
as many Canadians have pointed out to me
but know it's perfect
perfect perfect it
is okay guys unfortunately we're going
to have to wrap up the
Q&A see we're about to get invaded by
how long did we just
do thanks for coming good
[Applause]
night